Jaakko 13 year street cop here
my old man died when I was 10 it cut
deep and I grew up with no one having
two boys on my own now and loving to get
after it on the street I worry about the
risk how do i balance being a the spear
with ensuring I stay around for them so
first of all we have to recognize that
there's no way that you can ensure that
you stay around and in fact one day you
will not be around one day none of us
will be around that's the fact and that
actually doesn't matter what your job is
and there's all kinds of things
regardless your job whether you have a
car accident whether you have a heart
attack whether you have cancer or a
plane crash or random violence or some
random accident there's all different
kind of ways to die now you are correct
that the death rate of cops is higher
it's higher than a normal civilian but
what like loggers construction workers
they all have a higher rates of death
then a cop roofers roofer if you're a
roofer you have a higher rate of death
than a cop any drivers anyone that
drives for a living whether there are
trucker or whether they're literally a
traveling salesman they have a higher
rate of death than being being police so
no matter what you do there's a chance
that you could get you could die and
I'll tell you what I think about this
sometimes in the reverse of like what do
you wonder what scares you about what
your kids do if your kids are engaging
in activity that could be dangerous
whether it's parachuting whether it's
rock climbing whatever like there's
things that your kids could do that they
could die and what you could do is not
allow them to do it
wrap them in bubble bubble wrap and not
allow them to go anywhere and guess what
even if you do that there's still a
chance and you've taken away you know
their growth so you can look at it the
reverse as well that there's some things
that you're not gonna be able to control
and no matter what you know your kid
could you could say I don't want my kid
to join the military and so they go to
college and what happens in college they
get hit by a drunk driver they like
there's enough bad things that could
happen in either one of those situations
and same thing with you and your job you
could go get a job doing something
unless you get a job that's just
straight up you know in an
administrative situation with note with
very limited commute and very limited
driving then that might increase your
chances a little bit then but then you
you know then are you doing something
that you actually like to do so there's
your dilemma so what do you do in a
situation like this what you do is you
train and you prepare and you vigilant
and you take care of your sons obviously
and you would explain your job to them
and you explain to them why you train
hard and you explain to them why you're
willing to make a sacrifice to keep
others safe including them you you work
every day to keep them safe as well and
if you explain that to your sons they
will grow up with an understanding of
service and discipline and duty and
courage and honor and by the way if
something did happen to you the model
that you set for them would have massive
impact would have massive impact on them
and how they would live their lives and
I believe it would be actually a
positive impact sure would they miss you
absolutely sure would they wish more
than anything that you could be back yes
but would they recognize that their dad
made this sacrifice yes they would would
they live to honor that sacrifice yes
they would
so that's one thing you can do if you
want to keep that profession now if that
if you can't get around that if that
doesn't make sense which it's
understandable if you look at me and say
hey Doc will I get it
I want my kids to be raised with honor
but I'd want to be there and that's more
important to me and if that's where if
that's where you end up then what you
have to do is plot out what another job
what another career is gonna be and like
I said then you have to make it doing
something that legitimately gets you
into a better better survival rate which
by the way outlaws just about every
outdoor job you could have so you're you
know you if you work in construction
nope that's not it
working as electrician no that's not it
working as a linemen nope that's not it
all those jobs all those outdoor jobs go
look at this statistics go Google death
rates in jobs and there's all kinds of
fisherman no forget about it you know
there's so many jobs that have a high
death rate where accidents happen so
what you're talking about going into the
life you're going into would be going
into would be an administrative job of
some kind and and if you think you can
do that and you think that'll be give
you the satisfaction that you want then
then it's a possibility think about it
but if you look at it and you think you
know what that's not for me then train
hard prepare build a great relationship
with your sons stay vigilant don't get
complacent ever and be aggressive I have
to throw that one in there because in my
opinion when when an individual gets
scared or gets hesitant or gets
overprotective of themselves I believe
they're in more danger not less danger
and more danger so if you think that
having kids having your sons is making
you less aggressive and more
scared I think you're at higher risk so
if you're gonna do the job you do the
job you get aggressive when you do the
job and if you can't then you got you
you might want to look and see if
there's other alternatives that are out
there the other thing I would say is
this how how often like you're a street
cop you've been there for 13 years
is there another department you could go
to is there some other way to serve and
and stay connected use your experience
in another in another way maybe one area
that has a little less probability of
getting killed again you got to look if
that's something you'd really want to do
so ultimately and I tell this to people
a lot is there's only one person that
can make this decision and it's not me
the only person that can make this
decision is you so think through it be
thoughtful you can even talk about it
with your boys depending on how old they
are but you can talk about it with them
explain to them and you know see what
they say you know obviously there's one
way that conversation go hey would you
guys be sitting what you guys want me to
die right of course what are they gonna
say oh my gosh quit that job immediately
we don't want you to do that right so
you're gonna have to think of I don't
know what the ages of your kids are but
you have to think through that one
whether how you address it with them but
certainly I always look at it that
there's risk at everything you do you
might as well take risk doing something
that you love doing and that you know is
helping other people and you know
setting a good example for your boys and
if that doesn't make sense
cool find and find a different job